welcome to this video okay let's see
playing international master here from
Australia why not oops not that one the
Berlin defense and that's the first game
of the session at early in the morning
so i'm not i'm not really objecting to a
somewhat dull position ok it's played a
sideline of them of the the Berlin this
is in fact possible if I take now and
play d5 he has got the possibility to to
force a draw yeah I can show you this
afterwards this is the way to play if
you want to keep it a bit more a bit
more fighting d5 I show you later y94 is
some problem in terms of playing for win
okay it probably wouldn't have forced
the draw anyway I mean what what's the
point in such a blitz came to force a
draw for like one rating point but you
never know sometimes people are just
just don't want to play they just want
to get some meager points okay f form
yeah Bishop f5 he plays maybe g4 even
mm-hmm sorry um yeah that's possible
okay um so should I should I react to
that play something like f5 mmm yeah the
Sun the protected passer is not the
problem but he will be will take and
this will of course vastly increase the
range of this bishop I'm
sure maybe maybe I should go deform this
gives away c4d for but it opens up the
long diagonal from my bishop mm no
that's not not easy as all I wonder is
this g4 okay let's let's try i mean i go
back to d7 and then to c6 and I mean
this is a wide open King not sure he
wants to play G for this took me far too
long though ok could have played this
much quicker yeah that's clear I
expected that but I thought I can go
here and have this check this neat
square with a check and now I go d4 and
go Bishop c6 isn't this some good for
black yeah ok now you can get get this
pawn this is simply unimportant and even
the exchange you can get let's see him
just Bishop c6 young but if he takes a
rookie aight i can play he cannot take
on d4 because of the pin and he has no
good way to unpin yeah this is good
actually threatening rookie 5 him
and my next move might also be queen d 5
now I don't know why you played this so
quickly to be honest I don't I don't
really think that this is playable at
all for black so let's um let's consider
see 3 yeah that's that's maybe the only
move to to justify it but I have a hard
time to believe it rookie five ok me i
need to split up otherwise it does not
really make a difference that he played
it in such a such a spec know how to
call it so loose ok i can take rookie
three that's probably ok but and do I
have something better rook d5 this
Quincy form that's not so great can go
Queenie seven maybe
yeah I'm not sure not sure what's the
best best way to play Quincy for I have
fluke c5 yeah okay and now to e3 on now
maybe here I didn't want to take the
Queen Soph oh this I overlooked hmm now
that's time morning yeah yeah that's
really awful completely unnecessary as
well now maybe I should have exchanged
screens play hooky 3k what white was
doing was simply terrible to be honest I
mean this is ok but it's not a
refutation
okay what is this 50 seconds check I
will get be three when I look at 65 yeah
okay it's not so easy to play this with
30 seconds
check check check yeah that was only
hoping for some state made stuff there
is a TM black resigned yeah but this
wasn't I mean okay shouldn't deuce the
endgame but it it spent too much time
trying to get trying to view this and it
was probably probably simply bad 22 to
go to e3 okay let's check how black can
win Rookie for as the first one how to
win that's minus three this should be
okay yeah it's simply terrible he opened
up the the long diagonal on his King and
it's clear that this should should lose
some how but ok this is not this is not
so great in comparison yeah I should
take on before it's still a win here and
now rugby 8 the problem is that white is
completely tied down you cannot play
rookie one here and what what exactly
are you doing to get get out of those
pins yeah I should have I really should
have thought about it a bit and go for
this you can if you look at it a bit a
bit with a bit more bit more time on
your hands you see that white basically
has no move you cannot move the king and
threatening rook b3 I mean rupee one is
probably the best move something like
that I can just go here and are still
threatens us if he takes I have this
move with this threat now this has the
little tricks that you sometimes don't
see with a little time threatening this
and if he goes here I'm going to take
and I win the win the peace it's just
them just very easy even
so we cannot ever get to see seven the
few moves rugby one I still have this
move with the tempo like this and then
even here black whirlwind many porns
here simply because white is so tied up
this is just far better piece than than
the night yeah this was was a relatively
clean win and I simply overlooked when I
when I went to for this arrow key to is
still good for black but he I just
overlooked took a one which is an
embarrassing of course and I mean this
is still ok yeah of course but it's it's
it's over in terms of just a tearing
wide apart which would be the deserved
outcome yeah NTM it's it's just
completely equal around here I just need
to be a bit be more precise age 6 verse
was stupid already I can't clean this is
the simplest taking here and if you go
see I go clean u 7m this is the easiest
I'm protecting this and I'm getting the
a porn this is even a bit more more
comfortable for black but they ok it's a
draw but I will get the porn and I can I
can try at least I mean it's it should
be a draw but I can I can never ever
lose and here it's already a bit tricky
with the draw it still should be one
narrow gate six I could do yeah okay
that's easy even yeah okay I wanted to
play active but does not it does not
really am cut ah that was that was bad
um what what he did here to play this so
quickly it's just very bad I mean it's
um it's opening up the own position for
for no attack and should be punished but
I just played it very badly as well
alright thanks for watching